une page cinéma maintenant avec je vous
le disais dans les titres l'événement de
la rentrée vanessa paradis gérard
depardieu dans le film de jean becker et
lisa jean becker n'avait pas tourné
depuis dix ans et son été meurtrier avec
isabelle adjani
il met en scène une jeune fille rebelle
avide de vengeance sur la vie et sur les
hommes pascal deschamps et dominique
merlet
élu joueur comme le prénom de la mère de
marie qui s'est suicidé quand elle avait
trois ans elisa comme la chanson
composée par se faire qu'elle n'a jamais
connue et qu'elle rend responsable
dessus et lisa ou comment marie fresque
orpheline coup délinquante ballotté de
foyer en foyer
nora malgré les apparences pas connu
l'insouciance et lisa l'histoire d'une
obsession je suis mineur est ce que ça
veut dire tu veux l'argent non mais ça
n'est pas mari dans la vie est pas
arrivé tout ce qu'il arrive à ce
personnage mais je savais intuitivement
que elle pouvait être comme ça a été dur
de la deûle à convaincre papa aime tous
et on lui a même pas donné l'antenne
l'entité du scénario au lieu de nier que
les trois quarts et elle a signé tout de
suite parce que elle elle émue parce
qu'on avait tout le temps qu'elle
souvent et on se retrouvera jamais mais
pendant un mois ils filent à atterrir
je serai toujours là dix ans après l'été
meurtrier construit également comme un
thriller psychologique et lisa ne livre
que peu à peu haussé souffraient comme
autant de pièces d'un puzzle
91 m tous les partis
et cinq ans après noce blanche le film
de jean claude brisseau dans laquelle
tout le monde avait trouvé remarquable
vanessa paradis il transforme l'essai
sa part a dit c'est pas simplement
chanteuse où tous les ragots qu'on peut
à la population elle mais que c'est
quelqu'un de formidable
d'abord sur un écran mais même dans la
vie je peux vous le dire que c'est
quelqu'un d'une grande honnêteté et tout
beaucoup plus profonde qu'on ne croit